isn't it funny how terrified the
corporate press is though why are
journalists so scared that someone would
fire bureaucrats access because they're
friendly with it with the bureaucrats
now and because they get they have their
personal email addresses and their
personal home phone numbers and
sometimes they get Scoops so it's all
about access one of the hardest things I
think would be if he's talking about
getting rid of the deep State it's it's
the unelected officials right you can
fire you can fire all the heads of
departments you want but all of those
heads of departments have trained people
under them who think like they do who
they've groomed for those positions
farther up so it's not just getting rid
of whoever you're talking about whether
you're talking about CIA all of these
departments there's going to be somebody
that's going to come in there because
it's not like this is one generation of
a problem this is multi-generational and
it will take more than one president if
you're going to actually turn things
around